hi everyone in this video
we'll talk about fatty acid anabolism
versus catabolism and how it is
regulated
by hormonal inputs so
fatty acid metabolism is dependent upon
the metabolic state
whether you are fed or you are fasted
generally fatty acid anabolism takes
place
in a fed state whereas catabolism takes
place
in the fasted state and the choice
between fatty acid anabolism or
catabolism
is regulated via several hormones such
as
insulin or glucagon so in this video
we'll talk about how these hormonal
inputs
actually controls the decision between
between fatty acid anabolism and
catabolism
so let us look at in the cytoplasm
which is the site for fatty acid
anabolism
and we would try to compare these two
situations
with high blood glucose condition and
low blood glucose condition
high blood glucose condition is
indicative of a fed state
whereas low blood glucose condition
means
a fasted state so let us look at what
happens in high blood glucose condition
we know acetyl-coa carboxylase is the
rate limiting enzyme
for fatty acid biosynthesis which
converts acetyl coa
into melanoid now this melanoid would be
utilized to
generate fatty acids or help in the
fatty acid biosynthesis pathway
but the key enzyme acetyl-coa
carboxylase
exists in two forms a phosphorylated
form
which is a deactivated form and a d
phosphorylated form which is generally a
active form now
these two states can be interconverted
with the help of several enzymes for
example it can be activated
or de-phosphorylated with the help of
phosphorous phosphatase enzymes
and it can be phosphorylated with the
help of kinase enzymes
so in a bird's eye view all the hormones
would eventually modulate these kind of
phosphatase or kinase
enzyme in order to
regulate these enzymes
now when we have too much of glucose
this glucose would undergo glycolysis
and also this glucose would trigger
secretion of
insulin from the pancreatic beta cell
now this insulin would work on its
target tissue
and it would activate the phosphatase
enzyme
and we can clearly understand when
insulin activates the phosphatase enzyme
the acetyl-coa carboxylase would be
activated
or it would be d phosphorylated and
thereby
melanoid would be generated and fatty
acid biosynthesis
would be favored in short when we are in
fed situation or when we have high blood
glucose level
then fatty acid biosynthesis is favored
and it is proper to say that glucose
can generate a lot of fat if you
utilize the glucose then it won't be
utilized to generate fat
but if you have unutilized glucose then
it would be used
to generate fatty acids and that is why
sugar makes us
fat now let us understand what happens
in the low blood glucose level condition
or in the fasted state
so in the fasted state we don't have
input of
food so glucose level would be super low
insulin level would be low
but at this situation glucagon level
would be high
glucagon binds to glucagon receptors in
the target tissue
and ultimately lead to protein kinase a
formation
now protein kinase a activation leads to
phosphorylation of acetyl coa
carboxylase
into a deactivated state so ultimately
acetyl coa carboxylase under
fasted condition gets converted into a
phosphorylated
deactivated state as a result the
conversion of
acetyl-coa to melanoid does not take
place
right so this acetylene coe
now cannot generate fatty acids
instead it would be utilized to generate
other products such as ketone bodies
now we need to understand the fastest
state in bit more details
so let's take an analogy if we have a
lot of money in our wallet we can ex we
can
use this money to buy drinks or shopping
or let's say movies but if we don't have
money in our wallet
then we cannot do this kind of expenses
we have to
think of savings right it is same for
the body
when body is deprived of metabolic
inputs
or deprived of sugar or food input
then whatever is existing in the body it
would try to utilize that to generate
energy
so one of that substrate is triglyceride
present in the
adipose tissue under starvation that
would
release the fatty acids and the fatty
acids would be utilized in the liver
right so how it is utilized so inside
the liver let us zoom into the
mitochondrial membrane in the
matrix so in the mitochondrial membrane
you can see there are transporter
systems which are known as carnitine
palmitoyl transferase and these
transporter systems
exist because fatty acid cannot directly
cross the intermittent inner
mitochondrial membrane
because it is impermeable so with the
help of carnitine
transporter fatty fatty acid carnitines
are transported inside the mitochondrial
matrix
now inside the mitochondrial matrix
formatory coe or any kind of fatty acyl
coa eventually gets converted to acetyl
coa
so fatty acid breaks down breakdown take
place
in the mitochondrial matrix and this is
under fasted state because in fasted
state carnitine palmitoyl transferase is
active now then question comes
what happens in the fed state in fed
state
in short statement carnitine palmitoyl
transferase
is deactivated and i'll tell you how
but imagine if current in palmetto
transferase which is the key
transporter taking
acyl carnitines inside the mitochondrial
membrane is deactivated
then there is no chance of fatty acid
breakdown right
and indeed in case of
red state we have a lot of energy right
and we don't
need more fatty acid breakdown to
generate further energy
so fatty acid breakdown process would be
halted whereas
anabolism would be favored indeed
melanoma alcoa which is the first
uh raw pro raw material for fatty acid
biosynthesis
blocks the carnitine palmitoyl
transference
now we know this conversion of melanoid
from the acetyl-coa is catalyzed by acc
right which is in turn augmented by
insulin
so under the fed state infilling ensures
by indirectly blocking the carnitine
permeable transfer is that
the fatty acid breakdown does not take
place
so that's the role of insulin
in the fed state via melanoid it
prevents
carnitine palmitoyl transferase and
thereby fatty acid biosynthesis is
favored
whereas the breakdown is halting so
in this video we pretty much looked at
how
hormones such as insulin glucagon
and also metabolic state can modulate
the decision of fatty acid breakdown
versus
fatty acid biosynthesis now obviously
under fasted condition adipose tissue
would take the fatty acid it would
generate acetyl coa right
now this acetyl coa which is a product
of fatty acid
oxidation would ultimately can move
into a tca cycle or
it can also generate the ketone bodies
right in the liver it can generate
ketone bodies these ketone bodies are
very important because ketone bodies
give
brain the fuel in a fasted situation
so if you want to learn more about
ketone body biogenesis or how ketone
body is utilized
the link is provided in the i button you
can click on the i button to get the
link
but for now if you like this video give
it a quick thumbs up and don't forget to
like
share and subscribe and don't forget to
write in the comment that how do you
like my videos and if you have any
suggestion
do write in the comment thank you guys